italien hat es geschafft die haben den
spritpreis tatsächlich gedrückt die
haben auch die spritpreis steuern
gesenkt und gleichzeitig haben sie
gesagt wir holen uns eine steuer die
steuern die die ölmultis zusätzlich
einnehmen
die holen wir uns zurück jetzt wie geht
wohl stolzen italiener die
subventionieren dem spritpreis ganz
stark die haben keine steuern
weggenommen die subventionieren die die
zahlen sozusagen den rest der bei dem
rabatt fehlt dann versuchen sie jetzt
eine eine steuer durchzusetzen dem
mineral und concertino vernünftige form
der umverteilung hinzukriegen das find
ich genau richtig aber das aber laut
achten sehr genau das tun wir aber nicht
hier 181 app selbst kostet im moment der
liter benzin in
italien also warum ist italien aus
italien da besser als sie als die ampel
ich finde es bleibt dabei das ist eine
subvention die im prinzip mit dem risiko
einhergeht nicht zu tragen und im grunde
die ölpreis der die ölkonzerne im grunde
zu kämpfen ich finde das ist ein das ist
heute nicht das mittel der wahl sein das
was italien macht ist interessant und
korrespondiert ja nicht zufällig mit dem
was wir in den usa erleben wo beiden
jetzt eine
vermögenszuwachssteuer einführen will
für familien mit einem vermögen von über
100 millionen us dollar da wird kein
gutverdiener kein mittel verdienen da
wird ganz schlecht verdienen da
überhaupt betroffen sein sondern es
werden die besteuert mit dem vermögen
und vermögenszuwachs mit einem vermögen
von über 100 millionen us dollar ich
finde das ist ein weg jetzt auch über
gegenfinanzierung von sinnvollen
schritte nachzudenken denen wir uns zu
eigen machen sollten und das lenkt noch
mal den blick auf die frage wie das
alles finanziert werden kann was hier
gegenwärtig auf den weg gebracht ja das
besprechen wir auch gleich diskutieren
wir auch gleich wir sprechen ja
ausgerechnet jetzt mit dem grünen aber
das senken von spritpreisen wie ehrlich
kann sowas sein app cisco oder sitzen
sie zu hause und freuen sich insgeheim
darüber wenn der spritpreis deutlich
über 2 euro geht ich finde das ist eine
reihe von schritten gegeben hat in den
entlastungs paketen die deutlich
wirksamer sind und die deutlich auch
gezielte ankommt bei der bevölkerung als
ein ausgesprochen ausgerechnet die 99
euro in ergebnisse zum inhalt
preis pauschale von 300 euro für die
bürgerinnen und hallo war das ist eine
maßnahme die gezielt wirkt aber noch im
übrigen auch zur entlastung gerade bei
erwerbstätigen erwachsenen über alle
einkommensgruppen noch ins führt aber
noch mehr besitzen sie zu hause und
sagen die wahrheit ich freue mich über
den hohen spritpreisen
ich plädiere dafür dass man gezielter
bei entlastungspaket vorgeht als über
spritpreis rabatte die ja nicht umsonst
querbeet bis hin zu eher konservativ
liberalen wirtschaftswissenschaftlern
mit großen fragezeichen versehen
verstanden und zu recht kritisiert
worden sind unter anderem deswegen weil
gar nicht sicher ist was dabei
verstanden anders m klasse holen aber
die basiert auf den spritpreis also
sitzen sie zu hause und freuen sich in
wahrheit über einen hohen spritpreis
weil sie ja sowieso wollen dass weniger
leute ein auto nutzen
wir müssen zu einer co2 bepreisung
kommen die dann allerdings wissen werden
soll dass sich alle bürgerinnen und
bürger mit einem klima geld das pro kopf
gleich ausgezahlt wird und im grunde das
was an belastungen
ökologisch vernünftigerweise ausgelöst
wird kompensiert auf sozialem wege das
ist aus meiner sicht eine vernünftige
verbindung von ökologie und sozialem
sowie wie sie anstreben sollten herr
schneider erbse möchte ja offenbar die
grünen wollen ja offenbar dass man vom
auto weg kommen ja das heißt sie freuen
sich über die steigenden preise das ist
generation lasten fahrer das ist
generation e-auto wen kennen sie in
ihrer klientel lastenfahrrad umstellt
das sind dem auto verdichter dadurch das
leben wir müssen bei der ganzen
spritpreis problematik sehen
wird wie rentiert mit den pendlern das
ist auch richtig so wir haben aber in
deutschland 46 millionen pkw aber knapp
20 millionen berufspendler nur dass hier
wird ja unheimlich viel
mitsubventioniert und im grunde genommen
bis jetzt so den höchsten effekt und die
höchste förderung hat der mit dem
höchsten hub braucht also dass ich das
kann natürlich 25 millionen deutsche
können locker auf ihr auto verzichten
die 26 millionen deutsche nutzen das
nicht zwingend um damit zur arbeit oder
sonst wohin diese und dann stellt sich
die frage wenn diese menschen
tatsächlich wenn diese genug geld haben
und jemand der sie in suv kaufte sauber
mal für 100 1000 mbit s sind nicht nur
gerade stehen das war der sprit 250
kostet der braucht auch keine entlastung
es kann keinen sinn sein dass wir
wirklich ein umweltschädlichkeit
subventionieren zweifelsfall mit solchen
rabatten und das ist auch unsere
kritiker also hoch zum genauen maßnahmen
getroffen wurden wir halten den ganzen
sprint rabatt für falsch